The former governor of Alaska,
Sarah Palin.
She has lost her bid
to win a seat
in the House of Representatives.
Now, Palin's
defeat is the latest political setback
for someone
who was once considered a rising star
of the Republican Party.
Joining us to discuss
this is Julian Zelizer.
He is a CNN political analyst
and historian,
as well as a professor
at Princeton University.
Julian, thanks so much for joining us.
You just wrote a very interesting
opinion piece on CNN.com.
And you make the case
that Sarah Palin has lost the battle
but won the war.
You say, quote, Palin's
political legacy will endure.
The former
Alaska governor was a pivotal figure
in mainstreaming
a new style of Republican politics
that ignored traditional guardrails.
Her brand of conservative
popular populism, weaponized social
and cultural outrage,
and mobilized working class Americans.
Palin, in short,
mastered Trumpism
long before
Donald Trump ever
set foot in the White House.
So, Julian,
how is it
that the person who arguably unleashed
this phenomenon
may now be out of politics?
Well, she hasn't
found the kind of electoral success
that she's looking for.
And it's unclear
the kind of political legs
that this kind of Republicanism has.
That said, it's pretty clear
how the Republican Party has changed.
It didn't all start in 2017.
And she was one of the figures
I talk about.
Newt Gingrich is being another
who gradually changed
what the Republican Party was
and opened the door to a very fierce
kind of reactionary populism
that has been prevalent
during the last few years for sure,
but started a lot earlier.
Do you think this rejection of Palin
by Alaska
voters should serve as a warning sign
to other Republicans?
In the same vein,
like the former president
who has just launched his
his, he's just announced that he's
running for president in 20, 24.
It might, but I think that I
would underestimate
how deep this kind of politics is
in terms of how rooted
it is in the Republican Party.
Parties don't change overnight.
Parties won't change
because of one midterm election.
My guess is the fact they control
the House will give them some sustenance.
And I think
it's going to take a series of election
losses, meaning
many years of losing,
not just in one seat, but for Republicans
to start to believe
that they have to change their ways.
I don't think the party is
feeling that way right now.
So the brand that Gingrich, Palin
and Trump
all embody,
I think is still alive
and well in the party.
So even after this blow to Republicans
in the midterms,
you don't think that they're going to
to change?
You don't think that
they're going to be able to to
cast Trump aside?
No, I think they might
offer a different version
of what we call Trumpism
and maybe that's a Governor DeSantis,
or maybe that's
the former president
trying to position himself
in a different way.
But as the story
you started with suggests,
that's going to be very hard.
But but I don't think the party
is going to change
as quickly as some observers believe
All right, Julian Zelizer,
we'll be very interesting
to see
what happens both to the party
and to to Sarah Palin herself.
Julian Zelizer,
thank you so much for your time.